We did these drills
and
he's he's pushing and this is what I
don't want. This is what I don't want.
This is what I don't want. And I'm not
trying to use this. So you you had
touched my arm. Remember how mush how
mushy it was? Okay.
I focus on my spine
and I release the tension that's
happening. So
there's no strain in my voice.
He has to do what I'm telling him. So he
has to push with his muscles, but I
don't push my muscles. And I just if I
feel any tension,
I release it.
I don't try for any kind of manipulation
for angles. I just where he's going. He
got tired. I just letting that go down.
This is loose.
Now I saw some of you you have foot
bandages.
Seems like it shouldn't be possible, but
it is possible
that you're bracing with your feet.
Okay?
And the energy should just go down.
Not not if you flex your legs, you you
can get some, you know, lower body power
in there, but the angle is cutting this
way through your legs as opposed to just
down like this. Okay. I don't feel the
the sliding on my feet. Okay. So, even
though um you might feel relaxed here, I
want you to scan your whole body,
including down here. Okay. All right.
Let's just just get a little bit. We're
just going to do a little bit of that.
Okay. Try because I know some of you
already got those wounds, but those
wounds will help teach you.
Just like the other days, you scan for
flexion and then release it. Keep your
spine extended.
And again, you're going to push pretty
hard. If you get tired, you can let go,
but you're going to push pretty hard.
Keep your spine long.
Release all the tension.
Let the tissues other than the spine
drop.
Try to keep
articulation angle.
Okay.
So
if we look at this
somehow
I didn't turn
somehow I didn't go backwards that
happened everyone agree okay when we go
to standing
I can't start using the other angles
because already when I braced on that
you can see that that came up that way
I have to figure out how Though I have
my legs, I don't use my legs. Do you get
it? Okay. So, I'm just here.
Weight just goes down on that leg.
You keep pushing. But how hard would you
say you're pushing? Okay.
But if you look at me, how hard does he
look like he's pushing? Not hard at all.
Okay, got it. Okay, we lift. We're
getting a little tired. But so if you're
like, "Oh, yeah. Okay, go to the other
arm and try it." Okay. If the other
person gets the idea, go to the other
arm and try it. It's not We're not
conditioning. We're doing a
coordination. Okay. All right. So, try
it.
Go onto the back foot.
Okay, I'm going to bring you back for
some instruction.
Remember
where does my elbow have to be?
Or how about where where can it not be?
Outside. Outside my shoulder line. It's
very common. We do this.
That that's not marshall. Your elbows
have to stay inside your shoulder line.
They can go to the shoulder line. They
can't ever go past the shoulder line.
Okay. So, make sure you're not doing
that.
Come inside your shoulder line.
How much going to happen in my elbow
as it What is the angle? Come on.
The compos angle. Show us how to find
it. Just relax and hang. Turn your
thumbs the way you're supposed to. Got
it. Everyone should know this. I taught
it to you. Okay. You just relax. And now
he keeps that angle of articulation. He
comes up and that is the tati. So here I
am. You see no tension and come up.
That's how far my hand is away. How far
my elbow is away from my body. And this
is laterally. So depth lateral. Okay.
And
here
is that right?
That's right. Not long in alignment with
the elbow, with the shoulder, with the
quad. Not here like that. Not here like
that. Not long in here.
And that's what he drives. And that's
what I put on the back foot.
You bring the elbow out and you tell me
what you feel different. Where's the
energy going? It's going down. Okay.
elbow in
and I'm here and I just release
at any point he lets go whatever.
Why should I ever go flying forward if
my energy was going down? Should I go
flying forward? Okay. The only thing I
should feel my foot got like
Okay. All right. Try it. Don't let go
yet. Just try and fix this anatomical
organization.
Avoiding the shoulder line.
Too much too much uh articulation in the
elbow. Chris
lang even with the elbow. That means
your cup in your palm.
and and Tyler, we're actually we're
going to have just the do this. Okay.
This is they have way more base for you
and we're not going to start at the very
beginning. Yes, sir.
Weight goes on your back mid foot.
When you feel yourself flexed, release
it.
Your elbows going outside your shoulder.
More extension.
Extend
your spine.
There you go.
So when your when your elbow goes out.
Okay.
And just stay this angle here. Just pay
attention. So here's your loud arm
with your elbows out there. It's no
different than if you have your out on
here and your elbows out there. They're
not in alignment. Okay. So, watch what
watch where the energy goes. And while
I'm pushing
in relation to your elbow, where is it
going?
It's going this way. And so the things
that have to keep it out start to flex.
You see that? So, I want you in the fall
apart
and we're here and and it's going to
feel different than we you could do this
all day long in in the other stuff.
Okay, so we're here.
Good.
Start to scan for all other tension but
for the spinal integrity.
Now you That's not going that way
anymore.
Just going.
And if let's do this. If you bend this
arm a little, now it goes into the
bicep.
So leave it. Leave the articulation
to the other arm.
Right there.
So you this doesn't move. Now energy
passes through it
to that leg back there.
Okay. All right. Okay. So again,
energetically
form doesn't form doesn't matter. So
this I don't have to take that there.
This I can still take in my back foot.
doesn't matter. He could give a weird
angle.
He's never going to get this hand
and I don't ever feel it in my shoulder.
But marially,
I want this alignment and marially if I
adopt that alignment energetically, I'll
have a better chance. Okay. So, we do it
largely. I want it, but also beginner
gets me in the ballpark. Let me do that.
Okay. All right. So, try that.
[Music]
workout.
Watch that elbow bend. Count it.
Not in the beginning.
Okay. And now we will start surprise let
go. Surprise let go. Okay.
Sometimes let go, sometimes not.
Sometimes on 1 second, sometimes on 3
seconds. It doesn't matter.
Just want to observe
You got to lock your spine. You got to
lock the top of the pelvis.
Watch your elbow, wrist arm, line
alignment.
It's a little high.
You go up here and start. Get yourself
in the ballpark.
You're already fighting it. Let it go.
First you onto that back foot. First you
onto the back foot.
My my force follows your force.
Can't let it bend over the top of the
pelvis. There you are.
Relax the spine.
Okay. All right. Keep going. Change
partners actually.
If you went with someone light,
next time don't go with someone like Got
it. Okay.
Let's go back first.
Lengthen your spine there. Lengthen your
spine. Don't Don't crunch your stomach.
Watch the rotation that's happening.
Travis kind of rotating.
Keep it still.
Okay,
he's going.
And uh
everything uh what I want you to do is
everything on the other side of your
body, loosen up.
Okay, got it. Yeah.
The other hand obviously has nothing to
do with this.
Should be able to shake it loose.
Watch the elbow bend or we will we'll
have to start smacking each other.
Get the right angle in your elbow.
loosely up. Shake the other arm. Shake
your right arm. There you go. And you
got to get a good grip, uh, Chris, so
that you can drive into him. There you
go.
You got your little center arms.
This is where you want.
See how much difference
Take the other side.
Try to keep that elbow inside.
This isn't loose.
Okay, this is what we want. Okay, try
again.
Risk it. It's okay if we get pushed
over. We're learning.
So, see how your palm's not on there?
Yeah. Because he's he's he's got some
weird angle on you. So, I'm shorter than
you. And he wants you to lift up. He
wants you to do it like that. Okay. So,
you just go like,
okay, you're just here like this. And
you're pushing into him. He keeps
wanting to pick it up. I don't want him
to pick it up. I'm just down here.
Okay. Try it again.
Don't pick it up.
Stay where you are.
Okay.
Why do you think that I can shake this
hand and not be pushed over?
Why do you think?
Exactly. Has nothing to do with what
we're doing. Okay.
And but at the beginning
you're going to you're going to
overshoot because we're not coordinated.
And I I say make that mistake. Flex
freaking everything. And then you start
realizing don't need that. Don't need
that. Don't need that. Okay. So
he he's driving.
I don't need that. I don't need this.
I don't need I don't need any of that
stuff right now. I'm having you lock
your spine. You see? But he's driving,
right? You're driving, right? And I
don't need any of the I don't need any
of it. Just change what's happening.
Okay. So,
why this is important is because right
now when I flex everything, I can't move
and I need to be able to move. And
that's where the second drill comes in.
But influence. It's not as complicated
as this,
but you're going to shift your weight.
It's a cultivation field, so it's very
simple. So, we're on the back foot. I
leave everything exactly where it is,
and I go to the front foot.
See, I did that. If you're if you're
over flex, you're like,
"All right." And what you're going to do
is under flex and then you got pushed
over. Okay? So that's what drill two is
working on.
You go to the back foot. Cool. And now
move to the front foot without the
rotation, without the push. Okay. When
you're the watch,
he does not absorb the energy. He is a
good barbell. Okay.
So there. And then I just move. See how
he keeps pushing? He keeps his arm
extended. Okay? Usually the person goes
like this. We don't want that. We want
the barbell to stay rigid the entire
time. Okay? All right. Try
Keep your feet flat.
But that that's what we're working on.
You see?
And don't pull. Don't pull them because
you're falling. Okay? When you go, you
let let go. You did your job.
So while you're keeping your arm
extended,
you you are okay. In other words, I
push, he goes back and he comes forward.
You didn't do that. But what you are
doing is this. You see, you keep the
same lock, the same feeling, and he
moves that same lock. Okay? Does that
make sense? Okay. Go.
You're turning. The energy is going out
the rotation.
As you're coming forward, don't tense
more.
Okay. So, I went to the box foot and I
came to the front foot.
What's that look like?
This is not
okay. So, we have a confirmation
that you are doing it right.
I'm not trying to project him. In other
words, I'm not going like that.
I'm just trying to go
here here
with this same structure
here.
Okay. If you go too far, you probably
wound up. You know what I mean? Okay.
Don't chase the effect.
Do the drill. Okay.
Change markers.
With someone light, go with someone
heavy. Personally, I would train with
heavy people.
Don't pull yourself off the back foot.
Watch your head angle.
Don't chase the attack.
[Music]
Okay. So when I said this that I'm sorry
be more specific. Okay.
It's going to be mid foot.
And the metric I want is the knee
position. It's knee toes. You see that?
When I go over here, this goes from the
yin
to the yang
there.
That's too far.
Okay,
[Music]
good.
Don't don't uh lift it up.
Your hand should not move in space. Your
hand stays where it is.
They'll come off the back.
Not pass
your lap.
Okay.
So again, what drill two is is doing is
just can I move this structure? That's
all us. Can I move this structure? Okay.
Um
careful
that when you are trying to move it, you
feel his resistance and you start to go
around it.
That's that same thing.
I'm
want
Okay,
there's all kinds of ways that we go
around it.
Instead, I want to make sure I'm doing
the opposite. So, yes, our hand
is at this level. And yes, his center of
gravity is at that level. His center of
gravity is not here. It's in here. Okay.
So, when I move myself at that
structure, I move his center
when I do this.
I'm not going to come up in the
shoulders
where I'm touching I move the center.
Okay. So, what would be the difference?
If we go if we're going slow, if I'm up
in his shoulders, you'll see that the
slack go there. If I'm in his center,
you'll because the body's going to be
unified. The shoulders aren't leading.
You see that difference? Okay. So, I
know it's heavy. I know that if I do
that, I'm going to lose the structure.
But that's part of the drill. Push into
the center. Okay. Try
Oh,
you you you went like that. You're going
like this. Okay. You want to in this
drill, you want to keep the same
structure. Just moving it from one
midfoot to the other with the same
structure. That's it. That's the drill.
Just move it to the other. Don't go
around the center.
Change.
You with someone light, go with someone
heavy with someone heavy. Sure, I'll go
with someone light.
Less, right? What? What do we do? I'm
trying to learn to lift. I'll use less
weight. I'll get the boosted. Okay. So,
that's work more on that. Am I doing the
movement the the the the um pointers
that I was skipping? And I stop testing
myself with that I project them or not.
Okay. Try again.
Lock your body. Okay.
Try not to use your arm. Keep the same
angle. Keep the same angle.
Bring your elbow inside your shoulder
line.
Went a little over the center. Went back
down.
Don't rotate. That's a different shape.
Okay, two pointers.
Don't waste 50% of your time.
So
when I push, I have the same spine.
I have the same ground pop. And I'm
pushing with that. I'm not pushing with
this.
I move, I push, he absorbs,
he comes back. And I keep that same
organization.
I had it in the beginning. It comes
forward. I changed it.
Had it in the beginning. It goes
I changed it a little. I held it for a
little and I took it off.
What I did
is I teach the people to do this and
people statistically
here. It's going to be weird, but it's
going to make sense because I'm not
finding him. I'm learning a skill. Okay.
So, the more projectable I become, the
more projecting I can be. Okay? So,
in all of these where I let energy leak
out, I'm not projectable.
But that would have been the same thing
where I'm trying to project. So I'm
wasting time. So you want to make
yourself projectable
because oh and I'll keep that
organization until that force entirely
disappears out of my body on its own. I
will not take it out of my body. Do you
understand? You guys understand? So, I'm
not I'm not doing He goes
I didn't do that,
but I didn't go I'm off balance. Let me
absorb it.
I let myself be projectable. Boom.
Okay. Now, I take it off. All right. If
I'm going into the wall or I'm going
into someone else, I'll take it off. But
I keep myself
as long as that force is still in me.
Okay, try it.
[Applause]
Whoa. What the heck was that?
Why is your hand so hard? Right.
Okay. Next pointer. It's a yinyang
world. It's a yinyang art.
It's going to make sense once I explain
it to you. But it doesn't at the getgo
is if I'm here
when I go to shift my weight,
that's all I got.
But if I go more yin,
there'll be more yong.
You understand? So, you got to you got
to resist the temptation.
I'll stay I'm going to stay here cuz if
I go back there, I'm going to lose it.
Okay. But that's what you want to do.
You want if you if you want to send them
flying, you have to bring them in. You
can't keep them out and then try to make
them go more out from there. Okay. So,
exaggerate the yin more, please. Go.
Get it. Get a new per Get a new person.
Don't turn your body.
Don't take the knee past the young face.
Don't extend your elbow. Everything
stays the same. Don't come off your back
foot.
Don't go around the center. Go into the
center. Don't go past your knee.
Don't extend your arm. Don't extend your
shoulder.
Get your elbow in.
Don't go fast
or
Go fast
all the way.
Don't chase the attack.
Watch your knee.
Watch the front knee.
Watch the front. Watch the twist.
Okay.
Drill three.
understands that there's a catch to what
we do. I call it a catch. I'm going to
catch the wrong aspect. I'm going to
catch it on the mid foot. In drill one,
I placed it there. Okay. In drill two, I
placed it there and then I moved it
forward. It was my weight. In drill
three,
I catch it. Okay.
So, if you pay attention, I'm not ahead
of him,
but not like drill two where I let him
push me onto it. I'm going to catch this
thing.
Okay.
The weight shifting still has to happen,
but it's going to be much smaller. If
you try to do the big movements, you're
going to get the same kind of prolonged,
let's call it now, sluggish
comparatively. the same sluggish effect
of your two. Okay. So, there's a timing
in here. Catch. Boom.
My weight's going here like that. But if
you go like that, it's not going to be
it. I'm showing you what my weight is
doing. Okay. I'm here and I catch.
Okay. Where do I aim? In the center.
Okay. Do I pass at all? No. No pass at
all. That was it. Okay.
stage barber
this I'll give you this bouquet this is
where we start seeing all of that stuff
okay don't go
that the one who's most projectable will
project the
And you want them to go out more. What
do you have to do? Bring them in more.
Okay.
Got to watch the organization.
Come. Come more in.
You're on the front foot. You staying on
that bracing angle.
[Applause]
Don't let your arm go in your mouth.
Your belly.
Okay. I don't I don't try to if I try to
push him, I'll usually wind up and I'll
usually extend.
When you feel like you want to push him,
I remember it's like you should have
gone down. No, he goes where he goes.
Okay.
Bigger people, more yawn, absorbs more,
takes longer. Okay. So, let's say I
going with you.
Wait, I go with Chris. Little sluggish.
Little sluggish. You see that? He came
in a little more. That meant he went out
a little later. There's nothing wrong
with that. The mechanics are mechanics.
The center his center is still being
seized. Okay, there's more yaw. There's
going to be more yin. That's going to
delay it because it's taking more time.
Okay, just be patient. Stick to the
mechanics.
More again.
That's all right. That was in the
ballpark.
Let him go again. Four more.
Good.
We were ahead of them.
We unwe.
No, you're still doing two.
Got it.
That's it.
You're changing your shape. Thanks.
too much.
Okay.
Um
when I'm doing,
for example,
we um
we did this stuff, right? We did the
adhesion
and that's what I did here.
Today we did the displacement
right
just like I'm not using anatomical
structures to move him.
Same thing here.
This is the same exact thing as his
young energy coming in and hitting the
ground. Okay. So his when I when I feel
him, it's the same thing.
which is why you see that
kind of effect. Okay, you understand?
Um,
that's the these two ways are the only
two ways I move unless something went
way wrong. So, they they have to make it
go wrong. Okay, which doesn't happen in
Khan because they don't resist or
assist. Okay. Um but in Khon something I
want
to come towards me is going to adhere
through it. Okay. Something that's going
to go away from me is going to be
closely projected through these two
engines. It's the same engine but
different y values are being put out.
You guys understand? Okay. So that
is what we're working on in a very
simplified form. I don't have to even do
tension. You see and inversely though by
what I just said if I'm not doing
tension with these two hinges I'm not
doing
I'm doing something else. Okay. Um, so
yeah, this is so marshal that this is
stupid. That's what you'll hear from a
lot of people like who's going to drive
and and you know or they might be
thinking um
and let's let's the critics will do it
but some of Tai Chi people for example
the Tai Chi people will be I'm going to
just stand still and project you out.
No you're not. No you're freaking not.
Okay. Um, so it might not even be
in uh in China or whatever how I
generate force motion. Do you
understand? But the force I'm generating
is generated through this. Okay. So here
here I had, you know, a
a co projection on his leg, right? But
it could be the strike. So instead of
just shoulder shoulder and hip kind of
thing that the energy that I hit here
goes into the ground. I absorb it and it
comes back out. You get what I'm talking
about? And that's just that's just how
boom how I hit. His body did exactly
what you saw is happening here. Okay. So
this is obviously not a Marshall drill.
It's not going to be a one to one
transformation into it.
purposefully simplifies to
just get back. Okay, that's all we're
doing right now. Um, so I say this one,
I'm going to continue that great
question because there's a lot of
questions on that day. What do you mean
by cultivation field? What do you mean
by application?
Um, but also to free you from a marshall
end. Okay? Because your marshall then
you might think I want to send somebody
flying. I want to be able to send them
flying. And now what we end up doing is
something else because you can achieve
flying without this engine. You
understand? So you I can go like that.
He went flying but that's not the engine
that I want. Okay? Does that make sense?
So you got to free your mind.
and you're trying to line up and you get
hip rotation. All right, you get your or
you're trying to extend and you get this
rotation or I'm trying to go here, you
see? Or I want him to go back. I want
him to go that way. So I but I'm not
going to go this way. You see? You get
it? So you got to free your mind and
just say what what is it? What the
teacher say I'm trying to do? That is
all I'm doing. If I can't figure it out,
who cares? you will figure it out later.
Just like I told you with Maya, I don't
care. I will teach her how to fight if
she wants to go down that route later.
But she's playing the game exactly like
the game was taught. There's no Maya is
not thinking at all. I'm ready for
multiple attacks. You know, May is just
playing a game trying to keep her flag
safe and get a fight. That is all she's
doing.
I I reference this book often, but if
you haven't read uh Enders Game,
it's very much like Enders Game. So,
this is a sci-fi book where
um the human race and the future is at
war with an alien race. They need to
have great generals. And what they do is
they take these kids that show high
intelligence and they just teach them
games. And the games get a little more
competitive a little more, but at first
they're just silly games and the kids
just trying to win the games. Okay. And
then later the character realizes,
"Holy there's a war. It's like
that game and he's putting it all
together." Okay. So, same kind of
concept here. All right.
Any comments, questions, observations on
what you felt, what you felt from
someone else?
I went over it again with some of you.
You want to comment on what that felt
like, comment on that. Um, but let's
bring it up to the conscious level.
You stand up.
Okay.
It seems like it shouldn't be possible,
but it seems to defy what I originally
look at.
Makes sense, but just looking at
that guy and bounce off one leg.
Yeah, initially it doesn't make sense.
Here's how I again I don't care how it
did it job. Okay. And again, the
ultimate thing is to change the
consciousness that is working there. But
for this you're like, okay, what the
is going on? To me, it's a
rebounding.
So you throw something at greater mass,
it's going to eventually bounce off of
that. Okay. So to me, um, like what if I
were like, what's it feel like? It feels
like when you push a beach ball into the
surface of the pool, like you push push
push push and like it's getting harder
to push it and when you let go, it comes
flying back. Feels like that. Um, so as
he has more y, I can feel like that the
beach ball's getting he's going like
that. And all I got to do is not freak
out. That's exactly what I want. Just be
patient. And then just going to hit the
ground. I'm just going to put that out.
Okay. Um,
I think there might even be some innate
elasticity in the spine. just the way
the spine works and forces going in
there. Do you know I imagine I could see
this. I would never go now. Okay, maybe
there's some uh not not necessarily
of me doing like a wave kind of thing,
but the force itself is doing a wave
thing just to the structure and the
angle of the spine. You see that? So
when it loads, it comes back up. Almost
has like a bow effect maybe. I don't
know.
I don't know.
But I think it's weirder
to think
that with all these hinges and
articulations and fluids and vacuums in
my body that I should act like a board.
Do you get what I'm saying? like you you
you hit the top, I'm supposed to go
flying. Like a board would do that. That
would be really weird. Let's say you're
trying to build a building. You're going
to want structural integrity, but you
come to me with a board that's all
slinky and fluidly. I'm like, dude, that
can't that can't act like a lever,
right? But somehow we that makes sense
to us. Like, you're you're a lever. No,
I'm not a lever. I just weird thing
today,
you know, when we were playing that uh
the game on Monday with the kids. Um
this is reminding me of that. I was
pretty impressed. um especially when the
the boundaries became shorter because
what a lot of us started doing was try
to push each other out of the borders
and virtually everyone was unpushable
outable but they were able to ground it
and I don't know whether what the
mechanism was but obviously the energy
was going down and then they were
redirecting the energy into the pusher
to allow them to not be pushed out but
to shake around to yeah to get enough of
the energy off of them to go to go
around it. Yeah. Again, that got pretty
narrow. You wouldn't think that everyone
would go fine, but no one lever has
to do something to us to act. Okay. So,
you know what they always say in law
enforcement, you know, you have this
terrible crash and they'll go, they'll
go like the person not a scratch. Don't
go, oh, drunk as not broke as
cuz they were all loose, right? As
opposed to getting that tension and now
acts like a lever on that. Okay. Um,
[Applause]
again, I would task myself with just do
the metrics until I get the experience
rather than trying to go. It is like a
like a bouncing ball in water.
Just stick to the metrics. Okay. All
right. Any other comments? Especially if
I went with you, whether it was just the
pushing drill or the progression drill,
any of them. I mean, it felt like
almost.
Yeah. So, I did one quick one on on you
in the corner. Boom. And it's it's
instantaneous like that. We talked about
that earlier, right? It's not this long
dragged out thing. Um, there wasn't a
lot of oomph in me. There was none like
that. But you come in and you're like,
"What the Okay, now again in that." And
now I'm your spine's already tilting.
You see? And now I my double leg. I'd
rather do the double leg on someone
that's going like that than someone
who's here.
Um, very similar to I'd rather be tenagi
at someone that's trying to get the grip
than someone who has a solid grip. Okay.
I'd rather I'd rather shoot somebody
with a hatchet when there's a bar
between me and I go, okay, that's a much
easier shot than
Okay, now thank you. That That's a lot
reducing my Okay. All right. Uh, we'll
keep working on it. Right.